subway now is offering free sandwiches  for life  if you get the 12 by 12 inch  subway hero and logo tattooed on your  chest or back  no you  cannot just  oh my god if i was a homeless person you  would why not oh my i would i would  literally save up enough for a tattoo  yeah go and get the 12 by 12 and then  it's for life you just said for life  yeah what are we doing here we're gonna  solve the homeless problem  if i was a tattoo artist i would give  away free subway sandwich tattoos yeah  to people that are struggling it is  funny to think about who pitched that in  the subway advertising meeting that was  like i know this is going to sound  stupid if they get the subway footlong  tattooed in their body  how long have you been working here  this is my tenth year okay what's your  name  my name's harold executive vice  president right now  how about being in a subway when someone  walks in and goes i guess  [Laughter]